so these talks are all between unions
between network rail and between
operators all over a pay offer so we
previously understood there was a four
percent payoff on the cards uh although
unions wanted that to be boosted up to
seven percent uh but the condition on
the four percent was all to do with
modernization as well so i'm joined here
uh by eddie dempsey if we just uh move
around here eddie dempsey general
secretary from rmt um so can you tell us
about what has happened in talks today
so we haven't had a proposal on pay
despite uh the company or perhaps the
government leaking a four percent offer
to the press
uh last time we were here in a
last-ditch effort to
get a deal before the strike started
instead of getting an improved offer we
were handed
a notice of compulsory redundancies uh
for our members we came back here today
seeking for that for it to be removed so
that we can negotiate a settlement to
the dispute but we have been told now by
the highest people in network rail they
don't have the authority to say that you
can withdraw that letter there's only
one place that could say that and that's
in the department for transport so it's
pretty clear the government have
scuppered these talks so now the strikes
remain on and they will commence
uh one minute past midnight tonight
so what what happens next what are the
next stages
well this is an escalation in a dispute
and that will be responded to in kind
i'll be going to seek direction for my
executive committee
but in the meantime rmt members will
never meekly join the dole cues in this
country to protect the private profits
of people who've been ripping the
british people off for years we will not
suffer that and we're prepared to fight
for it so we know strikes are going
ahead tomorrow strikes plan for saturday
as well but thinking uh further ahead
longer term what should uh passengers
expect to see happening with the rails
well as it stands it seems that there's
an escalation uh led by the government
uh in these discussions
and if there's an escalation in threats
against our members it will be responded
to
by an escalation in industrial action
from the rnc union so we'll now consider
our position but until our members are
given a protection for their jobs a
decent pay rise
and security in their work we'll
continue this campaign to pursue those
aims and um network realms spoke about
modernizing ways in which uh work is
done meaning job cuts i mean what are
your thoughts on that well there's a
real problem of that because it seems
the modernization that the industry
wants
uh is being uh fought over between the
train operating companies on one side
and network rail on the other right now
they're in a deep argument about who is
actually going to employ railway workers
in our stations so if the industry can't
even make his mind up about what
modernisation it wants it's going to be
extremely difficult for us in the trade
union movement to make a settlement on a
modernization program that works for
industry and looks after our people
thank you very much for chatting to us
mr dempsey
so as you heard that confirmation
strikes will continue tomorrow and more
strikes planned for saturday too